the SCP Foundation has gone up against a
lot of anomalies that can be best
described as demonic but few fit the
bill better than the demons and imps of
scp-5049 demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot a skin-stealing Enterprise
designing bespoke demonic disguises on
the behalf of seven mysterious demon
Lords anyone that the foundation has
managed to capture related to this
anomaly has been assassinated by the
demon Lords eliminating the prospect of
further investigation but what if the
foundation brought in another expert to
Hell a Bonafide expert in the occult
DC's devious demon detective himself
John Constantine maybe he can finally
give us the lead we need to bring down
those demon Lords once and for all and
with the help of the animatron 6000
we're going to find out exactly how that
situation would
let's rev up the machine and take a look
it was a cold night in New York if
you've ever been there you'll know that
most nights are but on this particular
night a certain chill was streaking its
way through the air as I see cold as the
grave this wasn't just a deathly gust of
wind or any other freak occurrence of
the weather though especially judging by
that piercing wailing shriek it gave as
it passed by I cry loud enough to wake
both the living and the dead alike and
hot on its tail chasing through the rain
dampened streets after it long trench
coat whipping behind him was the one man
stupid enough to try and catch it you
see this thing he was chasing was a
spirit some might have called it a
Banshee or a yanaki baba but all our
coat clad friend called it was a right
bloody nuisance as for who in heaven in
Hell or on Earth he was that's easy if
you were to rummage through the pockets
of a coat you'd find the answer along
with an interesting assortment of
mystical objects beneath the charms and
trinkets that he carried on this person
was a crumpled off-white business card
printed on its surface in simple black
lettering was one name John Constantine
and underneath along with a phone number
were the words Exorcist demonologist and
master of the dark arts although the
word master has been crossed out with
Petty dabbler written above our friend
John really hated putting on airs he
turned down an Alleyway just as the
spirit did it screams Rippling through
the silence dead end there was nothing
but a solid wall ahead not that it
mattered the shrieking entity lacked a
physical corporeal form but the sight of
an obstacle in its path caused it to
pause just for a split second a short
moment as it tried to think over or
through and that tiny little instance of
hesitation well that's what John had
been waiting for as he ran towards the
spirit he reached into his coat pocket
pulling out a lighter its surface was
engraved with a phrase in Latin that
read Fiat used
meaning let Justice be done though the
world may perish that had long been
John's Credo to stop at nothing to
achieve righteous Justice no matter what
the cost or how bad things got
admittedly that was a little easier to
accomplish when you owned a blessed
liner striking at John breathlessly
uttered an incantation to command the
Holy Fire Within his hand caught Ablaze
as he took hold of the flame barely
feeling the pain of it burning casting
it towards the screeching Spirit a
bright orange streak shot forward an
ensnare of the runaway creature it
hovered above the ground driving and
thrashing in the air as it struggled to
free itself from its fiery bonds shaking
his hand to extinguish it Jon reached
into his other pocket looking for the
small jar he'd put there to his horror
the glass container was gone Constantine
frantically patted the outside of his
coat trying but unable to find it he
must have dropped it during their Chase
and without the jar he had nothing to
trap the spirit in typical he grumbled
to himself turning to look at the
shrieking Specter wriggling its way out
of the flame Jon looked around for
something anything he could use to
contain it finally he spotted something
left discarded in the alleyway it was an
empty Whiskey Bottle filthy and covered
in Grime well suppose this will have to
do Constantine said aloud to no one
other than himself he was a bit of a fan
of his own voice even if his
overconfidence did regularly cross the
line into arrogance placing the
bottleneck up on a dry patch of ground
John Hurley pulled a piece of chalk from
his pocket he started to Mark the
asphalt creating a circle around the
bottle symbols taken from ancient
languages and magical texts surrounding
the unlikely vessel his hands are
decides Constantine took a deep breath
and began muttering in Aramaic to the
untrained era would have sounded like an
incomprehensible incantation although in
no uncertain terms John was just telling
the spirit to pack it in and get in the
bottle before you wake the whole city
with a final Screech of dissatisfaction
The Entity was pulled into its cramped
new home like a mystical vacuum cleaner
sucking up a cloud of dust with an
exhausted sigh Jon knelt down to pick up
the bottle the glass surface was warm to
the touch now that the shrieking Spirit
was contained inside Beyond putting the
bottle in the pocket of his trench coat
he had a nice cozy shelf back in the
house of mystery where he could keep
this Troublesome siren and let it gather
dust trapped and unable to cause harm to
any mortal ever again but it was just as
Jon Was preparing a spell to transport
himself back to his base of operations
but his cell phone started to ring hello
wow he answered bluntly he was too tired
for whatever this was
um hi is that Mr Constantine a female
voice as from the other end of the live
depends on who wants to know love John
replied my name's Emma a friend of mine
gave me your card they said that she
paused sound like she was sniffling they
said that you could help me get my
brother back as much as it had already
been a long night and even though he
might often act like he didn't care Jon
was rarely heartless enough to turn down
a request for his help giving another
sigh Jon told Emma he'd look into it but
she'd need to give him the full story in
person the coffee shop was one of the
few open this early as morning started
to Dawn over the city all of New York
was gearing up for another day of hustle
and bustle people shoving past each
other to ride the subway to jobs they
hated stepping inside with his usual air
of swagger and bravado John spotted Emma
sitting and waiting for him she had a
mug of coffee in her hands but wasn't
drinking it the lack of steam seemed to
indicate it was already Stone Cold you
must be Emma he greeted her doing his
best impression of a friendly smile
extending a handshake John Constantine
At Your Service oh hello Emma responded
awkwardly accepting the Shay you sure I
can't get you anything stronger Jon
offered as he sat down opposite stronger
it's eight o'clock in the morning isn't
it a bit early for that she asked never
too early in my book John chuckled dryly
picking up a menu and scanning his eyes
over it here we are breakfast lunch or
never battled demons on an empty stomach
so what can I do for you Emma yes not
even looking up from the menu still half
focused on what he was going to order
well then it began like I said over the
phone something happened to my brother
burn off Diddy Constantine interjected
yes and no not exactly she sounded
confused like she was aware that when
she was attempting to describe wouldn't
make any sense when she said it out loud
he did disappear for a few days actually
we've been living together since our
parents died in this tiny little
apartment so we can tell when one of us
has left it was like one moment he was
there and the next he wasn't sounds like
a pretty run-of-the-mill missing
person's case love John's side not
exactly my department your best going
off to the compass for something like
that I tried that Emma raised her voice
slightly getting agitated or scared I
told the cops Ethan was missing and they
filed a report but they dropped the case
when he John thought about making
another snide comment to get her to
finish her sentence who chose to wait
instead he came home just like that a
few days later the police questioned
Ethan and asked him where he'd been and
he just told them he had gone to a hotel
for a few nights she explained I open
and shut then John Shrugged except the
thing that came back it's not my brother
Emma continued trying to hold back
frightened tears it looks like him and
even sounds like him but it's not Ethan
we think something happened to him
Constantine pondered maybe I don't know
about possessions and demons and all
that stuff but I was told you might be
able to help as much as I'd love to help
you out I'm afraid I need a little more
to go on than that John admitted a tiny
shred of sympathy in his tired eyes I
recorded this Emma exclaimed producing
her phone that's part of what made me
call you since he came back Ethan well
not Ethan he started staying up late at
night doing what exactly the Paranormal
detective asked chanting she answered
hitting play on her phone the audio
recording started it was faint but John
could just about hear someone growling
it was a human voicemail as expected but
it sounded all wrong Ethan or whatever
was pretending to be him was making
noises closer to that of a wild animal
than a person speaking in a garbled
unintelligible tongue that sounded
distinctly demonic John's experienced
ears what was he doing the night before
it disappeared he asked after a solemn
moment's pause just sitting at home
watching TV nothing out of the ordinary
Emma answered but specifically John said
with urgency in this voice what was he
watching uh I I don't know if she
exclaimed it was just flicking through
channels but there was hardly anything
on that late except ads leaning back in
his seat John tutted to himself shaking
his head demon Dan you old codger he
muttered it was demon Dan I'm asked I'm
sure sorry love John replied dodging the
question but your brother's gone and
right now there's some nasty glider from
the pits of Hell itself using his skin
as its own personal human disguise we
need to find it and send him all the way
down south South Emma Echo too confused
to cry you mean like to New Jersey John
smirk dryly oh much further than that
love he chuckled now where would Ethan
usually be at this early hour normally
he isn't up this early he'll be asleep
back at the apartment perfect
Constantine clapped his hands and stood
up from the table ever seen an exorcism
before hurriedly Emma escorted Jon back
to the apartment she and her brother had
shared there they found Ethan or rather
the thing pretending to be him seemingly
laying sound asleep it was only as Jon
approached hands raised cautiously but
the disguised demon Rose and lunged at
him snarling like a rabid animal again
luckily while the entity within was a
powerful agent of Darkness the outer
shell it was wearing was still mostly
human a quick blow from a frying pan
connected with Ethan's head thanks to
Emma and knocked him out long enough for
Jon to make the preparations clearing
the floor ripping up the carpet to gain
access to the floorboards below John and
Emma shifted the unconscious Ethan into
the center of the room around him
Constantine began marking out a ritual
circle on the woodwork he'd brought
along his bag producing a series of
candles from it placing each one at the
point of a pentagram he drew within the
circle buried in the bag were a few
extra tools of his many trades some
extra spell books holy water and even
some hallowed brass knuckles he pulled
one of the knuckle dusters out and
pocketed it he hadn't used them in a
dog's age but better to be safe he
didn't answer before Emma chimed in
watching the demonologist at work come
again John replied as he started
painting runes around the pentagram when
I asked you who demon Dan was she
clarified a right pain in the backside
I'll tell you that for nothing he
chuckled think of him like the used car
salesman of the underworld I've only
ever heard stories mind you I wasn't
certain until you mentioned that Ethan
was watching ads on the Telly so why
Emma asked this theme the Dan guy he has
his own commercials spot on John Smurf
he runs some place called demon dance
discount homunculus Depot the ad appears
on your TV usually at random and then
Dan starts Hawking in Wares you know
real salesman type battle infomercial
lock what is he selling though she cut
in her voice telling John she had
already half figured it out but didn't
want the answer to be as horrible as the
one in her head John paused for a moment
looking up from the nearly complete
circle of occult symbols us he replied
plainly human beings once the ads over
the nearest door becomes a gateway to
his little corner of paradise whoever
sees it ends up there that's when Dan
howls a person out Scoops out their soul
until they're just a husk that's what
happened to poison here Emma sniffled
holding back tears but why demons need
vessels love Constantine answered they
can well be running up about here in
broad daylight that's what Dan does he
takes him apart them back up turns human
beings into bespoke skin vehicles for
the worst hell has to offer with the
circle finally complete John retrieve
one of his spell books in a vial of holy
water from his bag it was time opening
the book to the right chapter he
splashed some of the Blessed liquid over
Ethan laying in the middle of the circle
instantly he woke up again growling
angrily as the water singed his skin
like burning acid even through its
disguise it was still enough to Sting
the demon who went to lunch at the
English Exorcist again only to find an
invisible barrier blocking its path the
spell John had cast was working keeping
the monster contained for now yo the
demon gurgled from inside its skin suit
lifting a finger to John you are known
to us Constantine oh yeah he replied
sarcastically my reputation has a habit
of preceding me
indeed the creature replied chuckling in
a mocking fashion we know what you've
done your transgressions your mistakes
owe so many failures the great John
Constantine nothing but a fraud that's
enough out of you mate John spat
flicking through the pages of his Tome
looking for the right incantation your
mother and father the demon growled
Marianne Thomas and Cheryl your sister
was it worth it John a spell to make you
a powerful magician was it really worth
the fire that claimed their lives Jon
forced himself to ignore the demons
taunting beginning to mutter a spell
under his breath all the while he was
aware that Emma was standing next to him
he could see her concerned frightened
look out of the corner of his eye and
then poured a fenceless Astra the hell
spawn continued practically handed over
to nergal on a silver I don't at all
thanks to you John I told you John smirk
finally reaching the right passage
that's enough the whole room shook books
flying off shells as if full force of an
earthquake had hit the apartment in fact
it was worse than that it was as though
a tornado was blasting through the place
magical gusts of wind throwing
everything into disarray images
bombarded Constantine's mind the sights
that Ethan would have seen that night he
was taken he could see the commercial on
the TV the logo for demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot appearing on screen in
baby blue bubble lettering then there
was the monster himself demon Dan his
dark green skin patches of thick brown
fur appearing randomly over his body
next came the sight of the store itself
the rose upon rows of hanging human
corpses all hollowed out shells ready
for Dan's demonic customers to slip
inside but all the while John didn't let
up sling more holy water at the
disguised demon he shouted the words to
the spell as loud as he could repeating
the entire passage over and over inside
the circle the creature thrashed and
growled hovering above the ground as the
hellish host was forced out of Ethan's
remain there's seven Lords are ever
planning their Invasion the demon
snarled you can't stop what's coming
Constantine if I had a quid for every
time I heard that John chuckled with a
final deafening crash the body finally
dropped back to the ground still and
lifeless Emma couldn't help but scream
as she looked at her brother deflated
emptied inside and now left as little
more than his empty skin no time for
that love Constantine urged her pulling
his phone from his pocket and typing out
an urgent SOS text now we're in real
trouble what the hell do you mean real
trouble Emma yelled sobbing
uncontrollably as she cradled Ethan's
hollow body well demon Dan's not gonna
be too pleased when one of his customers
complains about what I just did John
replied checking his phone Jen texted
back yet this was an emergency so he'll
probably be here any second now
practically On Cue the front door to the
apartment swung open an outstepped demon
Dan himself he towered over both John
and Emma almost seven feet tall on his
long goat legs and even uglier than he
had looked on the TV I should have known
he bellowed showing off Rose of pointed
teeth as he laughed
if it isn't the hellblazer himself
you've got some nerve messing with my
business little man and you've got some
bloody cheeks snatching human beings for
your little hustle might John retorted
slipping something out of his coat
pocket as he squared up to the grotesque
green skin demon a few words of advice
lad cash up pack up your bags and
clothes shop demon Dan threw his head
back and laughed a twisted inhuman sound
[Laughter]
or what he snarled with a grin I've got
a thriving Enterprise business is
booming do you really think you can stop
me all alone Constantine John smert
feeling his phone buzz in his pocket who
said I was alone a blast of magical
energy lit up the apartment as the
raven-haired woman appeared in a black
tuxedo jacket and matching Top Hat a
white shirt and bow tie beneath she gave
a flick of her hand right towards Dan
casting a spell yeah
before the Demonic salesman could
comprehend what was going on a portal
erupted behind him with enough Force to
drag him into it demon Dan tried
desperately to Scrabble to grip at the
floorboards only to feel a shoe standing
on his clawed fingers looking down at
him Jon was wearing something metal over
his fingers we are out of business mate
with the swing of his fist the hollowed
brass knuckles smashed into demon Dan's
face burning his green skin and sending
him tumbling backwards into the Portal's
magical pole he took her time Jon
jokingly scolded a thank you wouldn't go
amiss John Santana's Atara side I didn't
have to come just because you texted me
cheers Constantine said earnestly he
knew that demon Dan wouldn't be gone for
long but maybe a short stint in
purgatory would at least put a halt to
the satanic salesman schemes for the
time being although swept up in the
excitement of his temporary Victory Jon
didn't notice Emma's eyes quickly flash
an infernal shade of
now go check out scp-738 the devil's
deal to be made an offer you won't be
able to refuse or if you want more
clashes between comic book icons and
creatures of chaos then try Deadpool vs
scp-682 for more